man i'm tired gamers gamers you didn't
even have class today you're like more
dead than when you had class
doing the skype yeah
welcome to this episode of trash taste
where i don't know what we're talking
about today but i'm sure about the boys
who are awesome
don't know what we're talking about
today it's good to have a normal episode
uh
like we've had a few now where god i'm
finding it hard to talk now jesus
i need to like fire up my brain there
were so many things that i wanted to
talk about like a week or two weeks ago
but you just couldn't because we had
like themed episodes
yeah like okay for example i'm going to
go right into the toilet sure okay okay
i've had a few topics that i want to
talk about as well but we can just we
can just quick fire through every topic
that we wanted to talk about go for it
about three weeks ago i was scrolling on
the youtube.com app
yeah at like you know midnight pretty
late i was getting ready for bed
some reason this genre video started
getting recommended to me which was uh
about like dangerous caves
okay okay have you ever seen these
videos maybe i have
basically it's just about caves that
people go uh i think it's just
called caving where they go in explore
caves yeah right yeah
is it like uncharted and unexplored
caves or is it sometimes uncharted ones
sometimes explored ones
yeah and it was just one of those things
where i was like i do not understand
why people do this like i could not
fathom it so there was this one this is
one video i can't really was called it
was talking about the cave in the uk
yeah and this cave had a section in it
right
where the person has to crawl through
the cave on there like like like
you cannot turn around yeah right so you
you're crawling like this right
for like a mile yeah oh i feel like i've
seen that and it's like
just wide enough to fit a single person
one one person can go in it and you
can't turn around until you get to the
end of the part or the middle section
there's a part where you can stand up
and turn around i know it was like
i watch some of these videos and i get
anxiety just from like
not even watching just from the idea
thinking about it
and some people do this with uncharted
caves as well which to me just
blows my [ __ ] mind and i get if we
don't do it somebody is going to have to
be crazy enough to like
who's who dead ass looks at like a hole
that just goes on forever and it's like
i'mma crawl through this yeah so
it's horrifying because there was like
the thing about this video and the cave
is blocked off now so you can't get into
it right
like i won't uh you still can in
different ways apparently but what ended
happening was there was a flood
while four people were inside the cave
and yeah they just
obviously they drowned because they were
stuck in the part where you're crawling
i remember that scene from japan sinks
yeah it's like a horrible one i was like
i have seen you know i've watched
documents you've done horrible stuff you
watch the videos but horrible stuff you
know like
all kind of horrible stuff and nothing
got my like anxiety going like this
yeah and it was just awful like oh my
god yeah and
yeah i did see other there's youtubers
who their whole channel is that
they just explore caves that have never
been explored which is like
simultaneously the coolest thing
but also why the [ __ ] would you why
don't you just like review
you can make your youtube channel around
anything else it's so cool though
because like you sit there and and
there's uh someone was asking one of
these youtubers like why do you do it
why do you what are you climbing caves
it's like the only place on earth where
like no one can communicate to you
and no one knows anything about and it's
a secret to discover and then don't
worry
yeah go to space i think i don't know
about that oh yes i'll get on my rockets
i feel it's a lot
cooler maybe but there was this one
video
about this uh this cave uh in i think it
was utah
all right it's called like the nutty
putty cave right that's because
apparently the soil is over textured
naughty party yeah
yeah so apparently the cave is like
putty that just sounds like a euphemism
and there's like
so let me paint a picture of this cave
so it's basically this this cave is
essentially just
one cave that just goes down right deep
and
it was a pretty well explored cave so
most of this cave was all really like
really well documented and mapped out so
everything yeah so
it wasn't okay for like like super
stupid experts it was like oh if you
like caving you can go in it it's fine
yeah
and there's there's two path points in
this cave one way you're supposed to go
down and one that
is too too thin to go down right and the
other part is called like the birth
canal in this cave
because it's so tight right that you
have to grab
once you get your hands through this
cave you have to pull yourself
vertically down because it's too tight
so you have to pull your side
so what happened was right the reason
why this cave is now closed and why it's
famous is that there was a story
where this guy went down the wrong way
and he thought because it was getting
really tight
that oh i'm in the right point because
this is the the birth canals
so instead of thinking ah maybe i should
like stop wait for my mate you know he's
like all right
i should keep going so he keeps going
down a point that's too
small and just gets stuck head first
down a cave oh my god
and we're talking like like proper like
yeah yeah the whole thing
and it's it's really brutal this guy is
stuck there for 12 hours
and there's like tons of rescue attempts
from like people and eventually just
dies because obviously he's
upside down yeah yeah yeah it's just
horrible hearing this and also
could you imagine being a rescue worker
like having to get someone out of a cave
i feel like
being a rescue worker in that sense you
are as likely to die
rescuing the person at one point one of
the rescue worker gets stuck
with him because he tries to go down the
same way just to pull him out yeah get
stuck but luckily they get the rescue
worker out
but then i was thinking like is this
just a bunch of people
who are rescue workers who are trained
in like cave rescue because that seems
like harder than
the actual caving yeah right like you
already have to be good at exploring it
yeah yeah yeah right i mean how can you
even be properly trained for an
environment like this yeah yeah because
surely i feel like that's such a
specialized
job yeah because you have to set up a
bunch of winches in a cave that's not
set up for
you know also also like what what life
choices make you decide
yeah you know what i'm gonna do
something that's even more dangerous
than cave diving and that's
helping people who get stuck cave diving
you know at least
you know people who skydive or you know
do risky stuff like that at least
let's get a quick death if you [ __ ] up
you're right
with with like caving that's that's the
part that [ __ ] me up
if you're stuck you're it's just a slow
death and you're in a tight space and
oh i'm getting it i'm getting i'm
getting anxiety i'm claustrophobic and
that yeah
yeah yeah i was like exploring caves
that sounds kind of cool yeah i'm down
for that
exploring caves where i once i go in i
can't turn around yeah that scares the
[ __ ] out of it yeah
that sounds terrifying yeah i want to
turn it i want to be like [ __ ] go back
yeah because if also more often than not
you know it's recommended obviously not
to go alone yeah
what happens if the guy in front of you
starts panicking yeah and
there's nothing you can do you're like
because then you're going to start
panicking because you're like
[ __ ] i'm stuck the guy in front of me is
stuck because he's freaking out should i
be freaking out
he told me this was a good idea [ __ ] you
know like in the horror movies where you
know you're in a group
there's a group and then someone someone
says oh let's let's split up that's the
smart thing to do
you know like and you think who in real
life would actually do that and i feel
like these are the people who are just
like
making the decisions where you're just
questioning why the [ __ ] are you making
this decision right now this seems like
a really stupid that's why i hate
most like hot like modern horror movies
because they they always throw in that
trope as if people
watching this in the cinemas are like
finally someone made a good choice in a
horror movie
to split up also another scary thing
about being stuck on the ground
yeah no signal so you can't call for
help yeah the only reason the
in that that nutty putty thing is where
someone got helped because his brother
was with him
and was like oh he's stuck and went up
to get help yeah but that's brutal
imagine watching just your family member
just die
just slowly die that's horrible yeah
yeah i can't [ __ ] imagine it and i
don't know if i'm sorry i didn't start
this podcast
and to top it off it's not even like a
cool sounding place to die either you
know
it's like like bro at least died cool
bro what the [ __ ]
my brother got stuck in a cave yeah yeah
no it's like you know there's like a
difference between like oh yeah my
friend got
stranded in death valley and died versus
my brother got stuck in the nutty putty
and died you know
it's like it's a little unfortunate it's
sad as well
and part of the story as well it's like
he just had like two two
newborn kids or something like why
it's like the video starts he had a kid
he decided to celebrate by going caving
and i'm like no
why yeah it's funny because i've been
recommended like
i would say not like a similar genre of
youtube videos but just like in the
opposite sense which is
just youtubers who just climb really
high places
and like i kind of get that i don't know
why i don't
i i don't like similarly how watching
these cave divers
you get like uh claustrophobic i get
vertigo
watching these people just climb really
high places i i also have a fear of
heights so just watching
i just i i can understand that i'm like
all right one
you know normally climbing is like you
know arguably climbing a tall skyscraper
is probably safer than going down a cave
explore i mean probably i mean there's a
difference between the feeling of being
trapped
and just you know falling from a very
high place
i can see why you get that sense of
freedom which is
exactly the opposite yeah that's what i
think i can understand that you know you
get the view
and it's pretty cool i kind of get it
even though i know it's insane yeah yeah
like i'm not gonna lie either way a fin
a pass on this yeah yeah because because
like i got recommended this video and
the title of this video was
reflecting on the day i almost died and
i'm just like oh man this is a it's
getting a bit too real here
and it's just this guy who is climbing
up this really tall building in hong
kong
right and it's it's just like this pov
shot and it's just him doing commentary
over it
right and so he climbs up this really
tall building in the middle of uh
like from at kind of like dawn so before
the sun rises
and by the time he gets to the top the
sun starts rising and
so you have this really tall skyscraper
and on top of this skyscraper there's
just like this really
rickety scaffolding that goes that goes
like off like another mile or something
you know what i mean right
and so he he starts climbing up this
when it's when it's like dark and
by the time he gets to the top the sun
has risen and you can see the view
um and then it starts raining no
and he's up there by himself and in the
commentary
he he says he says that i had two
choices
either i could wait up there wait out
the rain and just kind of risk
someone would see me and getting a
rescue attempt and i'd probably get
arrested
or i could just attempt to climb down
even though that would be
i would be more likely to slip off and
die so of course
he decides
like like getting arrested and being
rescued this is literally the horror
movie split up or stating no that's
that's not
that's what i'm saying right these these
people make the decisions
to do what we see as like the dumb
decision
i feel like if you're the type of person
who's gonna climb up a skyscraper you're
gonna be the type of guy who climbs down
a skyscraper
i mean i guess in his head he was like
either way i have to climb down so
i might as well just do it now i think i
think there also is a fair amount of
people
who would rather die than be arrested
maybe
i think there is i know i genuinely
believe there's a section before
i don't want a criminal record so bad
i'd rather not exist i'm going to die
here
before i told it people who would rather
take that risk honestly yeah
probably because in some countries
especially about you get that [ __ ] oh
your life's ruined
you know true true america i don't
know most most developed countries yeah
i mean like it's
i mean i i find it interesting to watch
people would go through this stuff but
yeah i mean
i could never do it myself i i think the
most i would want to do is skydive and
maybe bungee jump but the more i hear
about bungee jumping the less
i want to go through it for me bungee
jumping is a hard part
because well i think it's bungee jumping
it very much depends on uh where you're
doing it and
what company you're doing it with is it
or is it some dude and it's mate with a
truck and yeah yeah bungie
are you in a country with health and
safety regulations yeah that's the
biggest thing i think about
i hear people like doing it in like
places where i'm like i don't think you
should be bungee jumping i've i've seen
and heard
more bungee jumping accidents happen
than skydiving accidents
so just like weighing out the ratio i
find that skydiving might
be slightly better also people bungee
jump over like uh
water more often than not and you don't
want to slap that water yeah yeah yeah
bye-bye a lot of water [ __ ] hurts
when you slap it at that stage yeah
that's that's for you sorry i mean it
hurts when you're like belly flop from
like two meters up
let alone alone like i do wonder i'm
like what
causes like what happens in your life
are you born wanting
to do extremes like explore caves or go
to extreme heights is that like
something you're born with or is that
something you like that has to be
something you're born with or is that
something that like
over your life something happens when
you're a kid and it's just you know no
because like i feel that you know
from a young age there's always like the
kids who are you know
going to be like yeah i'm going to climb
this really tall tree watch i was like
that as a kid
i would climb anything and then i don't
know what i think maybe the first time
you will you fall over
badly and you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
actually hurts if you fall i think it's
the difference i think it's the
difference between
when you fall off that tree and you hurt
yourself it's the difference between
[ __ ] i'm never doing that again yeah oh
[ __ ] that was worth it
yeah can you pinpoint the moment at any
point in your life where you've like
you know exactly where your fear came
from for something i mean
you'll be ready might be one yeah i i i
i still have that memory to this day for
me well i have a i'm afraid of heights
yeah but like not
too bad like it depends but you could be
i think like there's
an experiment on kids right some kids
are born like people are born with
naturally a fear of heights
yeah right right but i feel that my fear
of heights came from the fact that
at my parents place we have this kind of
spiral staircase that goes down
before and i fell down that oh no yeah
and
luckily i didn't like break any bones or
like hurt myself that badly but i hit
like
i think i was only maybe like two or
three years old when i did and it's the
earliest memory i have
yeah of me just falling down and i'm
pretty sure that
caused a slight maybe like the fear of
heidi's something
doesn't it scare you that like little
things that happened to you as a kid can
just like [ __ ] you up
yeah it makes me scared to have kids i'm
like whoa what if i like accidentally
give him like too much broccoli and he
won't have chicken and broccoli ever
again man like i've traumatized him
right
how do i know it's gonna traumatize the
kids that's the first thing you come
here
i don't know why i don't traumatize with
chicken and if
doesn't eat the [ __ ] crust i'm going
to be sitting there on the table with
like the bottle of whiskey being like
where are they where did they all go
where's the [ __ ] back button i used
to be really claustrophobic i don't
really get it anymore
but i used to be really much the kid i
know exactly why and it took me like
years to realize like oh that probably
was traumatizing
um so one time uh my our parents were
out and it was me and my brothers
messing around and we thought
bro that's just a suitcase we can do so
much fun stuff with a suitcase
for some reason so for some reason i
think me and my brothers decide we're
going to take turns
locking on each other in the suitcase
right
right so so uh i don't know why we
decided to do this again we were like
four or five yeah yeah so i i i got
locked in the suitcase bear in mind
for some reason i thought i should eat
my uh cocoa puffs in the suitcase
so i i was in my suitcase i was in the
suitcase just eating cocoa puffs right
what was the point of this what what
would you get out of it i legitimately
don't know why we did this i just have
this memory
and then they started a kid thing to do
and then my other one i thought it would
be funny to start flipping the suitcase
with cocoa puffs and then that was where
i drew the line i was like get me out
get me out of here that he wouldn't let
me out for like 10 minutes
and i was like i feel as well i feel as
well with that kind of like childhood
trauma it really depends on like what
your siblings did to you
yeah yeah yeah i mean i'm very glad that
i had siblings because i feel like man i
don't know i i learned
a lot of valuable lessons i think it's
because me and my sister we kind of like
think the same way in a lot of things so
like we wouldn't do something to the
other person that we would hate to do
this is if you have only child when you
have like three brothers
like i said man it's like [ __ ]
wrestlemania yeah yeah it's like
there's like so we would like genuinely
have like full fist fights yeah
like punch each other in the face yeah i
hear about this with like
sydney and russell had a similar thing
where like apparently they would just
like punch the [ __ ] out of each other
and that's just like sibling love i
guess
but it was like if if like if we if
stuff got really
like bad like we had a really bad
argument like we put into fighting
yeah i mean uh going back to with the
fear thing do you know what fear
like fascinates me uh i forgot what the
name is like tyrophobia or something
that's the the one with like the whole
phobia yeah triple phobia
the one where you like where you see
like a lot of a lot of small hormones
because like i didn't have a fear of
this and i think that literally was a
fear that got garnered because of the
internet yeah
because because we had like the lily
pond plants in thailand
and i grew up with them so you know the
little little seeds
so i i was used to seeing this site
everywhere so i had no fear of it and
then
watching enough [ __ ] youtube videos
about it about about this fear
i i slowly gained it over time because i
just saw these different like [ __ ]
disgusting disgusting photos for me it
wasn't even like a youtube video is
literally just typing triple phobia onto
google images
and just the first thing you see is just
this row don't [ __ ] show anything
don't show
don't show it in the video but you guys
if you want to then go for it i'm
warning you though it's [ __ ] gross
i'm kind of glad that i had that though
because that made me like
understand because you know as when i
was growing up i don't really have again
even though i was claustrophobic i'm not
ready anymore i don't
give a [ __ ] now um uh like
i feel that that helped me understand
when people have fears that don't make
sense
yeah because before that i didn't really
get it like if someone was scared of
like
falling i'm like oh it's just a form and
you'll be fine but a little bit of
height it's safe
but now i get it because from that i'm
like this makes no sense why a bunch of
little circles
make me feel gross but now i get it my
fear of heights is really weird because
i'm it's only like
certain levels of heights that get me
queasy because you know like if you go
up to like the tokyo tower
yeah yeah there's like there's parts of
it where the floor is made out of class
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay i'm totally okay
with that okay yeah but
you take me onto the balcony of like a
10-story building and make me look down
that [ __ ] me up yeah i think it's
because
it might be because like say with like
you know tokyo tower like the glass
thing right
yeah you know that is safe right like
you could stand on that
you can jump on that like man you trust
the engineering yeah i do it's like
it's like they wouldn't this is japanese
standards of engineering they wouldn't
put this here if there was a fear that
somebody could jump on this and you
could break through it right like yeah
so i know i can stand on that look down
and [ __ ] around with it because i know
that's safe [ __ ] around
what are you doing getting your chisel
out no i could like i [ __ ] stomp on
and jump around and stuff just to like
freak out whoever i'm with
and i'm fine with that that doesn't tell
me all cause i know that's safe but
you put me onto like a balcony right and
i know that nobody won't do it
but the fear of somebody could come
behind me right now and just push me
over the edge
that's what that scares me that's true i
i have that fear
um whenever i stand on the platform edge
in
japanese uh japanese trains
oh really yeah yeah because i've seen
enough anime
where the main character gets shoved off
and
and there's nothing they can do and i i
feel that so whenever i'm like standing
on the edge of a platform
i literally have to stand at a 90 degree
angle because otherwise
otherwise i just i just feel
uncomfortable i feel like someone could
go
up yeah yeah exactly because at least at
least if someone tries to push me on the
side i can like
try to stop the momentum but there's
literally nothing i can
i don't walk because like normally the
platform is so
full right so and people don't stand on
the yellow part which like the danger
zone yeah but like if i need to get to
the other side i'll walk on the danger
zone but
i won't walk there if the train's coming
yeah yeah i'm not risking being nudged
or something
but you know if there's no train if i if
i get pushed on the tracks i'll just get
back up
someone will grab me right i don't know
man i've seen someone get
like falling onto the tracks before
really yeah what happened did people
help him
i mean obviously like they have those
like emergency buttons that alert
everybody so like
i think it was it was obviously like
some drunk dude just out of his mind
yeah i think there's posters all around
the
japanese stations being like oh don't be
drunk i think it's something like
60 to 70 percent of people who fall into
the drax
are usually because they're drunk yeah
yeah which makes sense but yeah i saw
some dude
like kind of stumble around and i was
like oh god this guy's getting pretty
close to the edge and then
sure enough he just went oh wait there's
someone on our station one time i
remember seeing that
yeah there's a bunch of stretches and
stuff unfortunately they fell and hit
their head pretty bad
yeah well that's the thing right the gap
is big it's
really deep yeah so if you're not
careful you can hurt yourself even
if there's no training coming but yeah
do you guys have this like
like uh unfounded like feeling or fear
or whatever
whenever you see like a big red
emergency button that you shouldn't
press
and your mind's like what if i press
that
no i don't get that i totally get that
like
every time like you go through the
school hallways and then be like
the fire alarm yeah yeah every time i
would just stop and look and be like god
i want to press this
i've never gotten to search because it's
like i feel that's
i feel that's an experience that only
like
the point one percent of you and you
ever got to experience all right
that was almost a bragging right as a
kid i feel being like yeah i pressed i
pressed this button before we like whoa
how was it it's like
of course it's like any it's like
pressing any button because i don't know
what the
emergency buttons or the fire alarm
buttons you had in your school but in
like
british school or my school we had like
this it wasn't a button it was like a
very thin piece of glass yeah
you had to break yeah and i always
wondered what does it feel like to break
that piece of glass
like i i just want to know i just want
to know what happens yeah it's like what
does it feel like like does it hurt
like how thin is it how much how much
force would it take to press this to
press this button
i do think you know when you're on a bus
sometimes you see that little puny
little hammer
there'll be like this giant window and
there'll be this tiny little like it
looks like a
little pick an ice pick that's another
one every time i came back from school
and i saw that little hammer i was like
i want to use that
because i think what happens is when you
literally that thing like
touches yeah yeah i was on a bus one
time when the windows exploded
really really yeah so what happened was
is
i was in near the back of the bus and
it was in university and it was a
varsity event so they drove the bus
to the like one-hour university over
from from swansea to cardiff
yeah and um when we were on our way back
the bus driver went down the wrong road
now as you probably are aware
roads in the uk if you don't go on the
right one with the boss it's way too
narrow
right right so what happened was that he
went down the wrong road
and he had to turn around but it was
like a like the road was like this right
it's like a three-point
like yeah so he went down this way and
so he backed it up the hill to try and
turn around and as he was trying to
swing the bus back round
the the house that was in like the end
of this road had like a pointing out
like
uh thing on the edge of their property
right right like a tile
and so as the bus is turning you could
see i saw because i was sitting here
like on this side
and that was the side where the window
was right you could just see this thing
coming right and i think they were like
started screaming when they saw it was
getting
real close and it just went and just
exploded the window
wow oh my god yeah yeah and then the guy
obviously heard the [ __ ] shadow and
was like
oh so he backed up goes to try it again
boom other window goes and there's clash
everywhere
was was that like near any of the
students or yeah but they all ran
to the other side so like it was like it
was terrifying and then the
the the bus driver didn't stop or
anything he just like he
i'm gonna try this again he smashed i
think in total three of the big ass
windows on the side of the bus and then
just drove back
like normal i'm sitting here like glass
everywhere like
what do i do did the glass explode on
someone yeah but the thing is right uh
the windows when the
it's car windows do this as well when uh
they smash they're meant to
they like the way they're made the
windows smash into like non-shock
they're like blunt little little like
balls yeah they don't they don't like
cut anyone it's still a scary it was
[ __ ] terrifying
that's what happened afterwards what
happened was that we just drove
the last 20 minutes with no windows on
the side and then we got off and
everyone was like
what the [ __ ] and we all went and was
like what the [ __ ] just happened
and i'm sure that guy lost his job oh
yeah probably no idea what happened
university never said anything
no we didn't hear anything how old were
you guys
i was like 20. oh okay oh so this is
like a university bus this is my third
year of university and i was like what
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i just went on with my day
i was like all right that was weird
jesus christ yeah never heard anything
about that felt like i deserved an
apology for having glass
flashing my face was it loud yes
you ever heard glass explode no i
haven't
i have heard like the probably the
loudest sound i ever heard was uh
have you guys ever had like lightning
strikes like hit really close yeah
no actually no really like you could
feel the shockwave yeah at that point so
i i had one moment where like i
legitimately thought i was gonna die
but um it was in high school and like
the the front part of our school has
this like big courtyard looking thing
like and
it's kind of on an uphill climb so if
you're standing like right at the top of
the hill and look
you can basically look across the
entirety of the school
which is kind of cool so then me and my
couple of my friends were there and it
was like very lightly raining and you
could hear thunder off in the distance
but it wasn't like a thunderstorm right
so everybody was outside just kind of
chilling
and we had this like one really massive
pine tree i want to say it's maybe like
you know 15 20 meter tall pine tree it's
huge just like
on the other side of the school right
and i was looking at it for some reason
just kind of like waiting for the bus
just like what a beautiful painting yeah
no no like because it's so massive that
you know it basically just fills up your
entire view
yeah and then all of a sudden it was
just this like flash of white
and this the largest [ __ ] crashing
sound i've ever [ __ ] heard
and what turned out was a lightning bolt
had struck that pine tree yeah that pine
tree was probably only about like
20 meters away from me oh wow but it was
[ __ ] massive and it was crazy as well
because like we're at the top of the
hill so
you can see all the other students
across the courtyard and
everybody simultaneously was like like
that
yeah i [ __ ] myself yeah yeah and but it
was so weird because
that entire crash happened and for like
20 seconds the entire courtyard was just
silent
it was kind of just like standing right
and then [ __ ] seventh grader like you
know kids over
whose balls haven't dropped you ever
suddenly like
just got a [ __ ] shell shocked i know
it's just [ __ ] there's just a [ __ ]
panic across the school
all the teachers like [ __ ]
themselves the tree was on fire
yeah so like straight up it was just
like a fire
this 20 meter tall pine tree was just on
fire
satanic but it was crazy because it was
like it from i'd say between a
five-minute span
oh no sorry five second span it went
from beautiful
large pine tree to just a burning 20
meter log
bam bro [ __ ] crazy this episode is
sponsored by honey guys
listen we all shop online and we've all
seen the promo code field taunt us at
the checkout but
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
gentlemen
imagine it i am you're shopping on one
of your favorite sites
[Music]
keep going keep going when you check out
the honey button drops down and all you
have to do is click
oh my god apply coupons oh my god wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for that site
my god keep going if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop
oh my god gentlemen i gotta know what
did honey
save you money on pizza no way get out
of here clothes
are you kidding me that's practically
everything in the industry
everything you can think of honey can
save you money
gotta ask how much should you save using
honey about 20 bucks
on a pizza oh my god yeah because pizza
in japan is expensive yeah i mean i
would take anything yeah i could i could
i could buy a whole other pizza with god
what about you i saved 15 bucks on
online delivery for my clothes
wow i saved 15 on a new boom mic
oh look at me but did you know gentlemen
that honey has found it's over
17 million members over two
billion dollars wow get out of here mr
beast we found a new king of youtube
if you don't have honey already i will
come to your house and install it for
you
but you could also be straight up
missing out on free savings
it's literally free and installs in just
a few
seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and you'll be
doing
the boys are solid as well by supporting
this podcast so get honey for free right
now
at joinhoney.com trash taste that's
join honey.com trash taste
back to the episode it really was scary
i mean again like that was probably
i i thought i was going to go deaf
because that was it was so
[ __ ] loud it was insanely like the
other loudest sound i've ever heard
was um clap my ass yeah of course
you can't you can't escape from me snake
but
um the other one was we were playing
cricket
obviously of course as the obvious give
me some animation yeah
we're playing cricket and uh have you
ever felt like how hard a cricket ball
is
yes yeah that thing is [ __ ] hot it's
like a rock
yeah it is a solid piece of whatever it
is but um
we were playing qriket in school and uh
i was in the outfield
and one of the kids like kind of smacked
it really really high up into the air
and it was going towards one of my
friends and he was underneath he was
ready to catch it
he's like come on catch your catch and
catch it but i think he mistimed it
because the sun was in his eyes or
something
so the cricket ball landed right on his
phone oh
god the only way i can describe this
sound was as if
someone in the distance had slapped two
pieces of wood together
it was just like this clack sound
and the kid just dropped to the floor
like we straight up thought he died
because he just that [ __ ] is hard was
that like the [ __ ] mortal kombat
moment where you know like
like the [ __ ] skeleton
it's like a [ __ ] fatality right
honestly because it just it went
crack on his forehead and he he
literally just
dropped to the floor right and
he was fine like he had he had like a
massive bruise on his head but he
and this one's got a dummy thickness
yeah we straight up thought he died
we're like oh my god
the hardest i ever hit my head this is
gonna be a strange story so
i was in sex ed okay okay
let me tell this story all right so we
were in it was our i think second or
third class of sex education right so
you know how it is teachers want to seem
like how how old are you at this point
like 13 okay so the teacher's like that
we want to seem cool
yeah this one yes you sit on the table
so much though
you know you know i don't know why is it
is it a universal rule where the tables
in the science class are taller than the
ones in the other classes yeah yeah yeah
you have that as well yeah because you
you have like stools yeah it's like
stools
like large right so it's a pretty large
table and we're sitting on it
and uh so we were watching this you know
and we were all on the tables all
sitting together you know with the boys
watching the sex
and the girls obviously yeah so
on this day i decided that i was going
to forgo breakfast
i thought yeah i don't need a breakfast
i'm a king i'm going to go to my sex
education mother and i'm going to watch
it and i don't need no breakfast
so i was feeling a little queasy but i
was like that's okay it's okay
and i'm you're feeling you're feeling
who is watching the video i was feeling
queasy before and then i felt even more
queasy hearing about this stuff okay
yeah because i was 13 they were like
yeah so goo comes out of the woman's
thing and i'm like
right so i'm sitting there and i'm like
all right okay okay and then i'm
suddenly like i just start feeling like
oh whoa
this stuff's getting blurry and then i
fall
on my friend next to me right and my
friend thinks
classic connor classic connor [ __ ]
around yeah so it just shocks me off
and so i go from this like pretty high
tall table
like i bet fell on my friend i just donk
my head on this like
pure like concrete floor yeah and i wake
up
and i come too and i just hear like
screaming
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i look
around and all the kids have like ran
to the other side of the the uh the room
right
and i'm just waiting here like what the
[ __ ] is going on i can't see [ __ ]
like because like my eyes are so blurry
yeah it's so hard
and i'm like oh what's going on
like i'm literally i remember i sit up
and i'm like what's happening
yeah you literally fainted from uh sex
ed
i got so much [ __ ] for it as well
obviously that's such an anime moment
yeah right yeah um and obviously in
school i was like oh connor phoenix you
saw a dick
that's when i started fighting i'm
kidding so i couldn't see for like two
hours
right vision was blurry and i was like
[ __ ] am i blind
but then luckily it came through and i
think i was just very heavily concussed
by the dick blinded by they were showing
johnny sims his first word oh god
that's like a death sentence in school
man no it was okay
i mean so now you know not to skip
breakfast yeah that was my bad because
i i yeah i often felt pretty [ __ ]
sick all the time
uh so yeah that was my dick just didn't
help hearing all this stuff at that age
i was like [ __ ] that sounds disgusting
i hate like slime and goo so much so
hearing it come out of like body parts
makes me feel so gross um
yeah it's the way they phrase it too
right yeah because the only thing i
remember from my sex education thing
because i i think i was like 11 or 12
when we when i do first sexy
so already it's like for a lot of kids
right but like the only thing i remember
they taught us which is
the only reason i remember is because
it's so [ __ ] weird to this day yeah
but it was
dead ass the first thing the sex
education teacher said it was like okay
everybody get your index finger
and put it on the inside of your mouth
and feel your cheeks
and everyone's like okay and that's like
that's what the inside of a vagina feels
like
that's all
[Applause]
no no this is in uh elementary school
yeah but like
it was that's not the only thing i
remember
i i just certainly remember what it was
that like set me off and it was like i
don't know why the [ __ ] they showed this
yeah but they were they were talking
about i know this is way too much
information so here is a time stamp on
school we skipped talking about this
stuff so go and search it
is gonna like leave the room so they
were talking about um
discharge okay girls right yeah yeah and
it wasn't enough to just talk about it
yeah
there was they had this like re
reenactment of this
this girl who goes to the toilet and
they dead ass do a close-up shot of like
white [ __ ] on her pants and i'm like
that's disgusting why would you show
that
we're like 13. that's that's what like
made me feel gross
did you have to watch the obligatory
like woman giving birth yeah
i was gonna i was gonna talk about that
because i swear to god whoever was like
and it's
on a british tv there as well they
showed births you serious yeah there's a
whole yeah that's a whole tv show but
you had like specialist uh videos that
schools like bought to show it's like
[ __ ] awesome
it's so graphic yeah and i mean the
person who edited
like our video they must have known what
they were doing right because they okay
so
this guy [ __ ] with us this this this
old british guy was basically describing
the process of a baby coming out of a
vagina right
and so um and so what they used to
describe
what happens the process of this
happening is they take a rubber band
right he takes a rubber band and just
like he just goes
imagine this is the whole vagina right
this is what happened when a baby comes
out and he literally
stretches it like that and then the
class goes
oh and i [ __ ] you know they they then
hard cut
to like a baby that's just like crowning
and just like coming out
and i'm just like think back to that
moment and i'm just like
i think back to the moment i'm just like
the [ __ ] editor knew what he was
doing there
this is like not even like a cross
dissolve
just a straight up hard car he knew
exactly what he was doing
one of those like you know there's like
whooshes in like that baby's head
oh my god they were so disgusting i mean
obviously
i'm glad that i was taught this stuff
but at the same time did they gotta go
in so god damn hard and that [ __ ]
eases in yeah that's brutal i mean i not
like who no one enjoyed it no no no i
mean i was like oh this is interesting
everyone's like no what
the [ __ ] i feel i feel like it's a thing
that does need to happen though because
yeah obviously i'm glad that i taught it
because you know you speak to americans
and then you know sometimes they're like
i have
no sex education at all yeah i mean like
sydney
learnt her sex education through hentai
and i mean
that is why it's like what is it like a
lot of the states
they just say oh abstinence wait till
marriage that's legitimately like i
think
of many of the stories so i mean i i
think it depends on the state yeah this
is
education is abstinence promote
abstinence
yes yes so like christian school so so
it's not like
i think in england you have to do it but
you have to teach it by law right yep so
every like
like age 13 gets taught like how to
put on a condom how to do all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah how did you get
did you get like the [ __ ] banana no
it was so embarrassing this woman right
it was she was like have you seen
matilda in that movie yeah
like what's that that that woman called
the like the devil teacher in the
comments literally woman looked like
that
dead ass took out this like [ __ ] 12
inch dildo smacked it on the table and
she was like who wants to put a condom
on this
who wants to try and then everyone was
like what the [ __ ]
why is it so big that was
massive it was huge i got this from my
own collection
that was right that was why i like that
i remember that i went home that day and
i'm like
what is average dick size because i was
like i was like that cannot be normal
that is like that is 12 inches that is
just the girth of it was ridiculous
that was clearly her own personal wants
yeah
jesus christ yeah i had to do the banana
yeah i thought i thought that was just
industry standing yeah
maybe there was a banana and she was
like no i'm going to bring my
let me just bring my ann summers like
[ __ ] [ __ ] collection
so like where are we going because i
think what happened was they ended up
teaching it like
we had so much of it because where i
grew up was like the worst place
in uh the uk for teen pregnancies oh
there's so many there's so many that
happened where i grew up
and it was uh yeah obviously you know
the government was like hey guys we know
you're gonna do it just please
please don't have babies yeah yeah yeah
don't
do it properly yeah at the right time
remember like a few weeks ago when i was
talking about how my mom
told me that babies came out with the
belly button yeah yeah like
so like yeah she she uh she uh watched
the episode and she messages me the day
uh the day afterwards reminding me that
actually my very first sex ed class
which was in primary school i can't
remember how old i was i think i was
like did i have sex
in primary i don't think so i think i
had like a very early sex
yeah it wasn't like i i had two or three
during my entire childhood i think and
it just like
every sex had got like progressively
more graphic
like like the older you get which is how
it should be but
uh she reminded me that the first time i
learned that babies didn't come out of
the belly button
and came out of the you know it came out
of the vagina i dead ass didn't believe
them
i came home and i remember because i
remember i remember this so
vividly because i remember the very
first time i tried lying to my mum
right and it was it was like such a such
an innocent little kid lie
where i went to the toilet and i didn't
wash my hands um and she asked me if i
washed my hands
um and i said yes that was the first
time when i attempted a lie in my life
it's like the most vanilla lie and she
was like let me smell your hands
let me store your hands and i'm like oh
[ __ ] the first time i tried lying i got
caught so
that was that was embedded in me from
like from like a very early age just
like
people don't lie because people get
caught when they're live
yeah yeah so sometimes you believed your
mom yeah
my mom's like all right i won't punish
you this time but
let's just make a promise that we're
just not going to lie to each other ever
and i like me
bright-eyed like five-year-old i
believed her until like i hit
i hate teenage [ __ ] so i go to this
class and people
and their teachers are telling us how
babies came out of the vagina and i'm
just like
um actually
um actually miss i believe that they
actually come out of the belly button
i know this my mom taught me no
and she was trying to tell me no they
come they come out down down there your
mom um
i'm sorry your mother is sorry your mom
is wrong so you know
me being like the eight or ten year old
i'm like okay there are there are two
adults in my life that have said
two different pieces of information i go
back to my home
uh i go back home and i tell my mom mom
the teacher taught me this
she said you are a liar but you know
what you promised me
that we wouldn't lie to each other so i
believe you no
i believe you mother i know that babies
come out of the
belly button and she's just like
yeah she just reminded me that that was
a thing i can't actually remember when i
realized that babies didn't come out the
belly button
master just blanked that out yes thank
you mother for lying to me from a young
age
i know you're a liar now
i remember one time i had like a bit of
hair
sticking up and for some reason when i
put like water in it didn't go down all
right
i was like [ __ ] this that's real [ __ ]
annoying and i'm like 10 years old and
i'm like
i'm just gonna cut it it's in the way
because it wouldn't go down
so i cut like a chunk of my hair out
and then i was like connor what did you
cut your hair i'm like no
no mother of course i didn't cut my hair
she's like there's a piece of mistake
i'm like i think got trapped in the door
is all i said she's like she's like
you're so you're telling me
that it got stuck in the door and it
with enough force that it pulled your
hair out and i was like of course
if she's like let's try it again
i've never prayed for more of my life
that my hair gets ripped out
so you go to the door the hinge she's
like first of all she's like how did you
get your door
your head in the hinge at the end i'm
like
i have no idea so i put my hair in the
door
and i close it and of course no hair
falls out and she's like
what happened she's like okay mom uh i
cut it because it was annoying me she's
like why did you do that she's like i
don't know it didn't go down with water
that's what i normally do and she's like
you didn't need to do that and i'm like
oh okay okay
[ __ ] mine started earlier when i was
like still in like nappies and stuff
like that right
yeah yeah yeah like because i had this
really for some reason i had the fear of
sitting on the toilet
for some reason like because i think
what it was because i think i was like
two or three years old right it's like
the last stage of you
still wearing nappies right yeah and
like i really hated
taking a [ __ ] like
like i really like i was really scared
and i think it's because i think my mom
explained it to me earlier later
she was like i think you were scared not
to like actually sit on the toilet but
to like
flush the toilet because you thought you
were going to get sucked in as well
i mean not going to lie those those are
airplane toilets yeah yeah yeah
it's the airplane toilet fear and i
thought that same force was in my home
toilet as well
i had the same fear i just [ __ ]
remembered this yeah and it came from an
airplane because you know when you flush
the airplane
it feels like you're gonna get like
sucked into oblivion yeah when i was
like 10 what i would do is i would like
because you had like two seconds of you
press the button then it goes two
seconds
yeah yeah so you have like two seconds
yeah so i thought i had that in my home
tour so
at that point so two three-year-old me
was just like i figured out a resolution
just don't [ __ ] just don't
just i'm wearing nappies isn't that like
a south park
yeah i'm wearing nappies i just don't
[ __ ]
but like you know at that stage as well
i was like i was too embarrassed to
admit to my parents that
i literally just shat in my nappies yeah
so
what i would do is like i would hide
behind the couch
and kind of just like subtly do it
behind the couch
while my parents weren't looking
and my parents and my mom would and my
mom would like walk into the living room
and be
like joey what are you doing i would try
and get a refund on the kid if you're
doing that it's like it's like
uh joey what are you doing and i'm just
like nothing this is like
you're pooping aren't you i'm like
no my face is straining like
and my mom's like i can literally smell
the [ __ ]
what are you talking about go to the
[ __ ] toilet
and i would literally do that for like
the longest time until like finally you
know you get to the stage where you have
to get out of nappies right yeah yeah
and so i'm just like
for the first like i think you prolong
that as much as you can for the first
like two or three months out of nappies
i
dreaded having to take a [ __ ] i'm like
oh i had to like psych myself
being like all right i'm not gonna get
sucked in today you can do it
it was horrible man honestly i still
have uh like
i still have a fear of going to the
tortoise on airplanes just because of
that noise like if
if i i need to i don't mind it's just
not pleasant it's not pleasant yeah
it's like i just get like a small
[ __ ] flashback every time i hear that
noise i need to wear like
[ __ ] thick headphones every time i go
man
i'm turning that music off that's what
noise cancelling headphones weren't
exactly i i feel like because you were
saying that you didn't you'd never like
lie
did you were you never lying like your
whole life up to like 14 or whatever
like when
when did you start like you realize you
could lie
um i think i think it was when i
realized my parents lied to me
i'm just like i can't believe they've
bamboozled me like this
i just realized that i was like i
probably started to like lie a lot more
for a younger age because
i had brothers yeah right because like
you're constantly like you can't lie to
your parents because they're your
parents right they
they own you yeah you don't get to like
talk yeah because i i didn't lie to my
[ __ ] parents like i said
like i got caught right right right the
first time i attempted this so
after that i was like this is this is a
loser's game i'm gonna lose when i try
for me it was like when you'd like go
visit a friend or something and you'd
like
you know the friend would be like oh you
know i'm just gonna say to my parents
that we're here to do homework or
whatever but you know we'll just go to
my room and play games
and i was like no that's not gonna work
my parents would immediately see through
that [ __ ]
and i would see my friend doing being
like yeah we're just gonna do homework
and the parents like okay i'm just like
you can do that oh my god
i'm gonna do that from now on yeah i
think because you when you have like
siblings it's like
i don't know i feel like you end up
having to lie because you're always
[ __ ] fighting
yeah right but like i was such a
terrible thing because you have older
brothers right
yeah yeah i see because i was the oldest
in the family so i had to like
teach my sister to be like listen you
can you can lie to the parents
i've seen it happen before
[Laughter]
[Music]
to me learning i could lie or learning
the people i was like watching that like
one life hack youtube video that [ __ ]
that was literally an actual life that
was actually a little high life hack
oh my god but i feel like that's why
some people are just like
so bad at lying because you sometimes
you play a game of among us you can you
can tell who the good lies from the bad
lies
um i've always i i think i've always had
this you know this fear like ingrained
to me from a kid that i shouldn't lie
and even as an adult i have a harder
time lying than some other people
yeah that's why i hate playing games
like a manga something like werewolf or
[ __ ] like that because
i just can't lie yeah but isn't it a fun
place to just like
you know just to have like a safe space
where you can all just [ __ ] lie and
like
laugh at each other no because i'm like
i'm like i can't trust any of you
[ __ ]
like after this game is over like i
can't i don't think i'll be able to
believe anything you say because it's
fun right because it's like you get to
experience what it'd be like being
interrogated if you committed like
murderers why was that fun
i don't know it's fun seeing if you can
like if you can [ __ ] your way out of
it but you can never [ __ ] your way
out of it
we should know this sometimes that's why
that's why it's fun to watch
interrogation videos yeah
i'm glad i'm not that guy right now it's
like the reason why i watch league
esports rather than actually wanting to
play league myself
it's funny to watch other people go
through pain rather than ignoring
it myself that was a really weird
tangent but that's the closest that's
the closest comparison i can think of
people suffer not me
yeah pretty much i mean who doesn't i
don't know i think i think the reason
why our mangas
did so good is because it did give a
like a thing where you'd be like hey man
there's not many games out there where
you can just like lie and that's the
whole game
it's like lying and deceiving and that's
fun to get to do that and like blow off
some steam doing
i mean i definitely do enjoy it i've
played like plenty of games
of werewolf well i really enjoyed that
among us
i just didn't get to play enough games
to really get used to it
um because i was still at the stage
where they're asking me what i was doing
i was i was like
i don't know what to do i'm following
the map i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on
i like those games it was fun when you
would like realize after like one or two
rounds you're like i know who the
the good liar is i've got to take them
out so they
they don't get to lie i'd say i never
got to that stage because in my head i'm
just like
how am i going to [ __ ] my way yeah
but by the time i had started playing
among us there was already a [ __ ]
meta
yeah like it's like what task were you
doing and so and so okay i know you're
innocent
like i just felt i was getting smurfed
on i i i i i really enjoyed it but
i think after like the first two weeks
the novelty really warmed off on me
yeah but obviously it didn't on youtube
because it was like a headlight for like
four
entire careers were created from that
game yeah yeah i haven't seen anything
blow up that much in a
long time it's kind of crazy i don't
know i mean it really
i feel like i started watching twitch
content
way more after among us and four guys
really took off last year
and before that i had hardly had watched
any twitch streamers
at all yeah and the only live streams i
watched was like youtubers
uh v tubers back then but that was
mostly on youtube
um so it's it kind of really i feel like
i don't know i don't know if it's just
me but i like twitch streamers like way
bigger personalities than they were in
2019 i don't i don't know if that's just
my
perspective um but i definitely see a
lot
i definitely love which people at least
probably because we're on youtube right
and i think what has happened is that
twitch streamers their content that's
being put on youtube is doing much
better than before
right right i think it's you know before
the biggest channels you know would get
you know maybe a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand views yeah their videos
they uploaded but you know now the among
us clips are getting like
five six seven twelve you know
million views and it's like wow yeah
that is nuts
yeah well i i think it's because i don't
i still don't watch as much twitch but i
see
so many clips on my recommended and on
my youtube feed that's
it i can't not see it now and i'm i'm
way more aware of what's going on even
though i'd hardly actually watch twitch
yeah i don't know i'm really enjoying it
right now i've really enjoyed streaming
so much i don't know
you're playing like apex every day yeah
i'm a [ __ ] apex man so much
you found you you found your new
addiction yeah yeah i have you're just
gonna end up being like an apex streamer
probably i basically have at some point
yeah i don't know it's just i i feel
like because right now what it is is
that i just want to play this game and
i'm just like i just happen to put
the the stream on as well you see like i
can't
do that because like my not stream
gaming mode
and my stream gaming mode is like
completely different i agree
in my head i'm just like if i'm not
constantly commentating while i'm
streaming
then i'm gonna look boring whereas if
i'm off stream
i am [ __ ] silent for six hours yeah
me too me too yeah i mean
like when you when you're getting filmed
i had to like
really force like comments out of myself
but that's how i feel with twitch as
well where sometimes
i'm playing a game in twitch mode i've
sometimes i feel like i have to force
myself to say something this isn't like
my natural default self
i i think that's i don't think that's
normal though like no one normally just
talks while they're playing video games
themselves the thing that you
actively learn too i i feel like
sometimes you think
at least right or you i don't know
actually in some video games i
i i don't even like i don't verbalize
any of my thoughts even like mentally
you know you can like like mentally
verbalize your fault yeah i don't even
do that i'm just like i'm playing the
game it's just all like instincts i i
only got used to it because i used to do
let's plays on my channel but like
before that like first
you did let's play yeah my first couple
of let's plays i was [ __ ]
boring as hell just because i i was at
that stage where i was like okay
i have to say something i can't just
like keep advancing with the game
silently because i'm
on camera but as i did it for like
[ __ ] three years or however long it
was i just kind of learnt to be like
here's something i can say here's
something i can say
to the point where i found myself
sometimes in my non-recording gaming
sessions
commenting to myself i'm just like oh no
this is a problem it's like 2 a.m and
i'm playing final fantasy 13
and i'm commenting to myself
commentating he's like are you streaming
cherry no why
like no i was like my parents no because
i was still living in my parents back in
the time
right and so my parents would come in
being like who are you talking to i'm
just like
oh my god who am i talking to there's no
camera rolling i'm not recording this
oh yeah my parents thought i was uh
because i was always on xbox voice chat
talking people they thought
when i started voice acting they were
like oh connor's just talking to his
friends on xbox
so they didn't know what i was doing
he's just talking in funny voices
why is he saying the same thing over and
over again huh doing different
inflections that's really [ __ ] weird
oh never mind he's probably playing xbox
con is a weird one
got some weird hobbies right yeah i mean
i think my parents definitely when i was
a kid
they saw me as like the weird kid of the
like of like the four
right they were like he's the strange
one but normally things work out in the
end
he'll find his way yeah that's normally
the way that it was
i mean like growing up i do sometimes i
do wish that i did have brothers and
sisters
um because i feel like i don't know i
don't know i don't know how you guys
feel about your siblings but
i feel like there's nothing that can
want to be raised without brothers or
sisters
i think now that i've had them i just
couldn't imagine not being raised with
siblings yeah yeah the same i don't know
yeah i i can't imagine just having to
share everything though that's
well you don't have to that's why that's
why how you learn to lie
although i did have to share my xbox and
that was horrible we have to like swap
every hour and i'm like i can't even get
a good gaming session in here right now
are you kidding me
i mean that's why i'm glad like the
first like game console we got was game
boy advances
because we had one each that was the
first gameboy that was the first console
you got yeah
yeah or any like yeah well like any
console that we could actually
share right or wasn't like a two-player
thing because we had like the n64 and
stuff like that too but yeah if you have
two controllers you can play it together
yeah
but i can't quite do that on a on a
handheld console right now
so it was five it was [ __ ] fine like
you know sometimes i'd want to get on
the n64
play a one player game like [ __ ]
donkey kong 64 or super
64 or something you can't play that with
my sister yeah so i'm just like [ __ ]
what do we do let's get a handheld
console and just play whatever the [ __ ]
games we want together
problem solved man i miss being [ __ ]
stupid as a kid
i do because i i miss i had this thought
the other day i miss
how simple it was just to like find
happiness in something
right so my first game so my first game
console
all game device was a gameboy caller
okay right and my parents bought it for
me in france
and uh they were like what game do you
want i'm like pokemon
yeah i didn't know at the time so it
turns out the game is in french
obviously in france yeah um but somehow
still managed to complete the whole
thing
wow when i was like eight or something
and i'm like
i would not have the patience to [ __ ]
do that now no no yeah i don't know i
don't know what the [ __ ] was going on i
don't know what any of the moves did but
i think like eight-year-old me
had just understood that this set of
letters
did this funny thing that did a lot of
damage because i've just been playing it
so much yeah i think by the time i got
to the elite four i think nearly all my
pokemon were level 100.
oh my god was literally just trial by
fire right i was literally just grinding
and i'm like how the [ __ ] did i do that
i'm so dumb i wish being that dumb or i
could just throw myself at something
like that
yeah like i remember because i also i
mean i got the game boy advance but the
first couple of games i got were game
boy color games
yeah because you could play the game boy
color games in the game advance which i
was like oh my god technology
but um yeah i remember like the part
where i think about it now where it's
like
i definitely had too much time as a kid
that i could not sink into my adult
hood was when i managed to on my pokemon
sapphire cartridge
i played it so much that i maxed out the
in time clock
oh my god like i found out that on
pokemon sapphire on game boy advance
is it one thousand hours yeah 999 hours
99 minutes is the furthest it will go
did you just leave this thing on no
that's how much i played it
i see it man when you're a kid you just
get obsessed every moment because
especially the game boy advance like
looking back on it now this thing's
[ __ ] tiny
yeah you could put that in like jeans
pocket or like a jacket pocket
take it everywhere the best john because
i think it was literally on wheel kids
was the game boy
advance sp oh yeah oh that was so good
only the cool rich kids yeah bro the sp
was like the best one cause that [ __ ]
like
just it would literally fit in your like
your tiny child jeans yeah yeah it was
amazing
i remember i remember one of my japanese
friends brought it to school
and it was like boys check check this
out
it was like whoa and it was like and
it's got a backlight on it
that was the backlight completely
i think actually the first model of the
sp didn't have a backlight it was like
the second model oh really it's just the
more popular mod like that yeah
yeah yeah but uh i had an sp and i got
one cause uh
my friend got one and i saw him playing
it and for like christmas i was like mom
i want nothing more than a gameboy
advance sp
and you know what game i played the most
on it oh [ __ ] gba game
i played pokemon trading card game oh
you played that game
yeah yeah that's so good right yeah i
mean i remember like oh god
sorry i i had a finalization of the
story uh one time i thought you know i
was so addicted to this thing right i
would literally
walk around the house with it i would
sleep with it oh yeah of course
yeah if i was walking down the stairs i
would play game boy walking downstairs
yeah yeah
i was going to do the table i'd be there
if i was going to better play it yeah i
would even
if i went to pee i would i would play
with it okay so i would pee with it
one time i dropped it down the toilet
not sure how it happened i was playing i
was playing pokemon trading card game
because that was the cartridge that was
in there yeah i was playing it while i
was peeing you know you know you're like
12 you're
a little dicks out you're like yeah i
don't know how i dropped it i dropped it
and i was like
how do i explain this how do i tell that
i don't have a gameboy
sp anymore and uh
yeah it didn't work and did you lie no
because it smelled a piss as well i
for some reason i checked if the pokemon
trading card came still worked
still worked of course because i plugged
it into my uh the old gameboy caller i
had
yeah but uh yeah so i had to go to my
mom i was like mom um
so this is kind of like embarrassing uh
uh
i dropped my game boy down the toilet
and she was like
how did you drop your game boy down the
[ __ ] toilet
and i'm like i don't know i just you
know i just really enjoy
playing it and my family [ __ ] rinsed
me for like five years
yeah that was my kid i'd [ __ ] read
something did you know how expensive a
gameboy advanced sp
is at that age they loved it purely for
the comedic purposes every time we would
meet someone like
this is callum he's he's very successful
very smart this is connor he dropped his
game boy down the [ __ ] toilet
and i was so sad for like four months i
was literally every window i was like
that's what i do did you ever get
another one i did six months later for
my birthday i was like
wow really yeah i don't i'd like
literally i remember like for six months
i was like playing game boy
color again yeah she's playing pokemon
trading card game with all the shitty
game boys
parents are nice man if if if i did that
my parents would never buy me a game
cartridge i think they felt
so bad for me because of how like
distraught i was and i think they
thought i was going to get over it but i
was sad for like half a year
well yeah it's like dropping like a
[ __ ] it's like dropping a laptop down
yeah yeah
i could not get over it and i think my
parents at some point were like
all right i think we should get him
another one or maybe he's like not gonna
recover
maybe he's never gonna let this go then
i wouldn't have i wouldn't have let this
go
yeah because like for me game boys were
the only game console or like handheld
consoles that
i could actually get every game i wanted
and that's because
um every year we you know visit our
family in thailand
and um there's there's always like that
one
store that my my parents would take me
to and it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't a legit nintendo store
i don't know if you could tell but uh
you basically go in the store
and you didn't they didn't have the game
cartridges they would just have just
just a book
yeah and you'd go for this book and you
tell these people
which games you wanted so like my entire
life i would have to wait
like a [ __ ] like one year to get two
games
one was for christmas and one's my
birthday and that's like the n64
game boy was like this this this was
like the early steam sale
yeah i would just like the humble bundle
yeah i would just go i would just come
come in every year and be like
[ __ ] i'm about to buy 15 games
for like 10 bucks or something like that
i felt good you don't like the chad like
[ __ ] like i'll take everything from
here to here please
like it was oh i [ __ ] it was such a
good childhood experience just like just
to sit down
and just i would be there for about two
hours and they would like every game
would have a different code
i would fill up this like a4 piece of
paper with just codes
i'm like mother give me all these games
and i wouldn't even play all the games
oh yeah but
it just felt good buying them i felt
rich for once it's because there was so
many i don't know what it was about the
game boy advance where it was like
didn't know there was a game of that but
there is on the gameboy advance yeah
well i i used to trade games with the
other kids
oh yeah i did that too yeah just the
games that i was done with like
scooby-doo adventure
be like well i i'm pretty pretty okay
if we go back to the lying thing i've
i've lied to one of my friends
so i had this [ __ ] like mickey mouse
game
on game boy advance which i [ __ ]
hated i don't know
i don't know where i'm going i don't
i don't know where i got it from i think
i got it from like a cousin's
hand-me-down or something right but it
was like
it was in that bundle of like two or
three like shitty like
not you know not known ip why does this
exist type of game boy advanced games
that you get
and one of them was this mickey mouse
like [ __ ] platformer game i don't
even remember what the [ __ ] it was
but uh yeah i was i was in school and my
friend was like oh i got the new uh this
is when emerald came out
right but i had ruby and sapphire at the
time right but i didn't have admiral and
i was like i don't really want to play
no no no no so i
so i was like so and and his friend
my friend wanted like to play this other
like i don't know if it was a pokemon
game or a mario game or something like
one of the mainline games he's like i
really want to play and i said
yeah i got that game
so what i did was i had the thing is i
did have the game
but i didn't want to give it to him yeah
but i had the box for it
no no so i
i did it i [ __ ] i [ __ ] debated him
and i slipped the mickey mouse game
into the barrio boss and i was like here
you go mate in box
don't have to check it now you can check
it when you get home right
and i took the emerald from him and i
still have that emerald cartridge to
this way
did this mom not call you your mom up or
like be like what the [ __ ] your kids
scam michael
i don't know maybe uh maybe he really
liked the mickey mouse game i don't know
because um in the uk there was these uh
like
you would have like footballer cards
yeah right
you would you know like fantasy
i don't know who was good i didn't care
about football i just wanted the best
stuff
because i was like it's a game i want
the best yeah and i was a real hustler
man i would do deals i'd be like that
that stock broker being like i can give
you this i can get
that maybe i don't know and one time i
was really annoyed
because uh this one kid he did a really
stupid trade with me
i was like sucks to be you man why did
he he gave me like give me like one
aldenio for like some
two players that were terrible and i was
like profit stocks
and i went home right i thought great
i'm looking at my collection of cards
this is amazing i've done such great
business today
literally like trump out of the deal at
school yeah you know making good trades
and uh i'm just chilling at home you
know admiring my collection and my mum
comes in being like connor what have you
done i'm like
what have i done it's like i've you've
tim's mom has called up she's furious
apparently you s you stole a car for him
like i didn't steal a card from tim
tim's a [ __ ] liar tim gave me
ronaldinho
but two of these shitty players she's
like really and i'm like yeah yeah get
him on the phone i'll tell him
what happened so i'm arguing with him
and he's like crying on the phone being
like
that wasn't a fair trade you scared me
i'm like i didn't scam you i don't know
who's good
i just saw that this guy was shiny and
you gave it to me and then i got i got
[ __ ] i had to apologize and give it
back
because he made a dumb trade i'm like
that's that kid got lucky that doesn't
happen in the real world
yeah that guy never would have never
would have got his money back yeah he
deserves to
take the album i was so pissed i was
like mom you interfered in my
negotiations do you know
you know how irresponsible that is that
kid should have learned the hard way
but he made a bad choice your mom
literally did like a caa drug buster
even like 12 year old me is like i think
he should deal with the consequences
you should learn now that this [ __ ]
hurts when you make a bad deal
he needs to learn a valuable lesson yeah
yeah he learned the hard way
clearly his mom is coddling him too much
and helping him what is this like the
[ __ ]
melvin capitalist like the [ __ ] uh
the stalker trade the yeah what's the
american uh stock trade like people who
watch the things
oh [ __ ] game stops getting out of hand
we have to stop this no no no
they literally did that to me this is
[ __ ] up that's terrible yeah i was
just furious
i kind of like this like talking about
this is bringing back memories for me as
well because the only time i've ever
like tried to hustle people
was doing like the pokemon card era yeah
yeah
there was so much i think it just got
normalized that just kids would just try
to hustle each other i'll give you a
hundred energies for ho-ho
please i swear like around the world
like you know we had like the [ __ ]
like the big like cocaine thing in the
80s but like the 2000s was like the
pokemon card equivalent
like everyone was like you know i'm not
[ __ ] scamming everybody for this you
don't know real hustle man
until you've been in school trading
pokemon or pogs or whatever the [ __ ] it
is yeah
i said that's like that's where the real
negotiations happen yeah
i'll tell you what that's right that's
why i learned the art of the deal
because like because like i'm from the
streets i like the hard way
because like i remember when i first
started getting into pokemon i i just
had like i just had like the worst gacha
like you know i
was i was buying so many expansion packs
i got i got nothing
so i had like no value that i could
trade with so i'm just like what what
what can i scrounge up that i could i
could sell to people with value
so going back to the uh the old like
game game cartridges that i would always
buy
so i i knew right even as a kid i knew
like
those game cartridges that you get that
says 400 games in one game cartridge
i i i like i would always buy them and
i'd try playing them but you know they
would have like
the shittest games oh yeah and it's
normally 30 games yeah like 30 games
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was like 30
games from like a game that was
like a chinese ripoff from like the
older generation there's like eight
different versions of tetris
yeah so i'm just like i don't need these
in my life i'm gonna try to sell them
i'm gonna try the
these for pokemon cards so because i got
these in like
southeast asia they were they i don't
know what it was like in your town but
like you couldn't really get like knock
off
game cartridges or knock off yeah yeah
yeah i was i only ever like i saw them
once and i was my mind was blown
yeah yeah how the [ __ ] did you get this
yeah so i i would go up to kids on the
playground and be like yo
you got a chinese charizard let me let
me introduce to you to my
game card yo this game card just has 30
games on it going off the recommended
so i basically pawned off these
cartridges that i wasn't gonna play
for shiny pokemon cards that's how i got
like at one point
the most like shiny pokemon cards on the
playground and then i left three of them
in my like [ __ ] jean pocket
in the wash and they were just gone
i i used to do something similar to that
but with yu-gi-oh cards
yeah because pokemon cards got very
quickly banned from my school because
like
all the kids were just like even during
class would just be [ __ ] playing
around with it right so we were like
all right well they the teachers already
know what a charizard looks like
[ __ ] they're in the end but they don't
know what blue eyes white dragon looks
like a pot of green
so let's let's so let's move on to
yu-gi-oh cards and i got so into like
the hustling of yu-gi-oh cars like to
the point where like
the peak it was the peak of um [ __ ]
you know obelisk
the [ __ ] like the f you collect the
five pieces of obelisk in your hand and
you like automatically win the game like
that yeah uh i remember that
like zodiac exodus is a different one
sorry exodia yeah so it's the five
pieces of exodia right yeah
you could that was like a starter deck
that you could buy right everyone
everyone had exodus yeah
right but not everyone had all the
pieces right because the exodia not
because you usually in those starter
packs you get one piece of exodus i
remember in the uk i don't know why i
distinctly remember this they literally
sold the deck that had all the five
reasons that you did buy flights because
for us it was like the starter pack was
the booster pack was like you'd maybe
get one piece of things yeah those
booster packs there was like starter
packs that had all of them yeah yeah
oh okay okay we didn't have that luxury
in australia so the only way someone
could
physically get all pieces of the exodia
was to do a bunch of hustling and
trading and get all the pieces
and so as like a 10 year old i had like
one exodia thing but i was like i love
this guy so much
i want to collect all of them all my
friends have all these other pieces but
they're not going to trade it to me
because they realize
the value of exodia on this market right
now
so i dead ass went up to my dad and i
was like father
you work for a printing company don't
you you have uh
high quality printers at your work
here's some pngs of exodia
could you uh print them out onto card
paper
and give them to me yeah yeah and he
full on like
printed out these like pirated [ __ ]
ex like and there were like
shitty like 240p qualities of like zodia
right yeah but as a ten-year-old
you don't know the [ __ ] difference
[ __ ] she's got mad flashbacks holy [ __ ]
so i would come to school and i'd be
like boys
terrible like princess one of them is in
like 1080p and the other is like
three pixels like whoa
it's like i can trade them off to you as
well if you want
and i remem i remember that like i
really really wanted
like i think there was like element
heroes or something and there's like
yukio xd
collection or something right and my
friend had them all
uh but i wish i looked a little closer
um because he traded me them and i
i you know i i was like yeah i want them
really badly
and then i got them and i was like oh
wait
they're like the description's really
weird
and it was all just like gibberish like
fake chinese sounding stuff and then i
realized when i looked a little closer
it was like printed all like [ __ ]
and i was like wait i just got hustled
yeah
it was all [ __ ] i was like so sad i
was like where the [ __ ]
you literally got scammed into a chinese
knuckle but like yeah you feel them they
look good
it doesn't look bad then you look at the
quality a little more and you're like oh
wait
yeah and then you select the text and
you're like why is that weird [ __ ]
like chinese sounding ass
thing do you want to see something like
if you want to see something
anxiety-inducing
right so i remember i talked about
rustic studies before
uh about um how he makes magic videos so
in his black lotus videos
uh so like black load is i think like
one of the rarest cards you've been
getting imagine
yeah the most expensive card so he talks
about how
you would like figure out what a fake
one is to a real one
and apparently one of the ways they used
to test this is called
the ben test right where you would take
this card
and you will literally have to bend it
like
like imagine this is the card so you
literally have to bend it there and if
it's a real card it won't crease at all
but seeing this like 2 000 card being
bent like that no matter if it bends or
not you
you i get anxiety and i have zero
knowledge about magic or any like
or any investment in magic at all all i
know is there's a video where a guy just
casually talking and he's opening packs
and then he opens it and he gets a black
lotus and he starts
like that it's so funny he's like
casually talking and then starts
freaking out i gotta i gotta find the
link to that
and then the other one is holy fish
that's a freaky black lotus
holy god that's like the one thing i've
been enjoying about like this resurgence
of like opening pokemon cards it's just
like how did that start people just like
casually talking and then just pulling
something really great
people turn into gambling that's fine
yeah pretty much because if you turn
anything into gambling it's ten times
more fun
is this how people feel when they watch
us roll for [ __ ] gadget wise yeah
exactly this is why i went on a rant
this is why gacha streams for a long
time did so [ __ ] well
yeah because people love it when like
that dude who [ __ ]
that japanese like streamer who was uh
what was he [ __ ] doing he was doing
arc nights right there's a guy rolling
in ark nights he was dressed up as uh
yugi
and yeah that's right and he had life
every time he did a gadget pull
like his life points would go down
and he was like screaming he did like
the full like voice acting
yeah he was voice acting and then he was
like and before and when he pulled every
time he would make it sound like he was
like
summoning he's like yeah he would like
draw that sounds amazing
it was a [ __ ] amazing really [ __ ]
good clip it's so funny hopefully we can
play it for like one second
it's really funny i'm like god that's
way too much yeah
i can't i can't be bothered to like come
up with like exciting things like that
for streams like
which is why i'm always impressed with
like how recently you've been doing
i mean i feel i feel like at that point
you
it's you have to treat streams the ways
the same way you treat youtube videos
yeah that's what i kind of
i do sometimes i mean right now when i'm
just playing
like like apex over and over again i'd
already say that way but like you know
when i'm
doing certain things i do think of it as
like oh just think of it as if you're
making a video right right yeah
and then just talk to the audience that
happened to also be watching you make
this video yeah that's the way i see it
i think that when you think of it like
that it's a lot easier to actually make
good content live streaming but if you
have don't have that frame of reference
of how does it feel to make a video
because obviously we have like five
years of experience of talking to the
camera
yeah making a video but if you've never
had any of those it's like how do i
how do i explain how you should behave
yeah
good content but then i think i've still
like a lot that i can improve on
so i'm getting i'm getting there i mean
it's a different tree it's it's a
different field but the way i see it is
that
you know i i think either of us can
become successful streamers i just think
i i don't have the energy to put into it
because i would have to
i'd have to use the energy to put that i
put into making youtube videos into
making twitch streams yeah i'm like
cool i mean there's there's so many
youtubers who end up just
stopping youtube and going to be a
twitch stream or vice versa yes
it's normally youtube has become for me
the one thing that is just stopping me
from making that transition is the fact
that
i wouldn't be able to take a vacation
yeah that that's like youtube you know
like i
before i moved to japan you know people
didn't know that i didn't do any work
for a month because i was busy doing
stuff but i prepared enough videos in
advance where yeah like everything was
running perfectly smooth you know right
but i was able to take a month off
exactly like was just like oh my god
that's nuts
you can't do you take a month off as a
streamer like you basically
people don't know yeah you just
disappear off the face of the earth yeah
pretty much yeah yeah which is why like
i don't know right now it's just like a
fun little
side hobby right now but you know i i've
noticed that i
tend to i used to you know when i would
uh do youtube videos
i would once i finish with the video i
would think about all right what's the
next
video i'm gonna make and i would think
about it all day what am i gonna make
what am i gonna do oh i can make this i
can make that
but like now i don't really think that
way i think like i plan what videos i'm
going to do
and then i don't really think about them
i'm just kind of until the day comes or
i'm making it i'm like all right trying
to make a youtube video which i feel is
more healthier in some ways but it feels
weird
it feels like i care less yeah i think
but i think it's a good thing
i don't know i've had to try and change
my mentality towards that as well
where especially hang out with you guys
and just or constantly compared to you
guys feeling like i'm
behind schedule and that's because i'm
i'm very like
my content is very like inspiration
based i find it so hard to work on a
video
if i don't feel like working on the
video i can't just like force the video
out so i have to basically try and
schedule
enough ideas ahead of videos i want to
work on
um in order for me to be able to meet
that like schedule see i think
inspiration is a little [ __ ]
i think i think i kind of you can't rely
on inspiration at all
right i think you know if you did what
you did for
the bbc yeah you don't have a choice if
you have inspiration or not yeah but
it's a different i mean
it's a different career path right i
mean it's comparing like a
office job to a creative path but i
think for any creative field it's
important to discipline yourself
to well yeah it's something you have to
learn of course
it's just it you know if i get
inspiration it's fantastic i love it but
it's so fleeting and motivation is so
fleeting as well it's like
you just have to discipline yourself to
just work i'm kind of like halfway in
between i think like yeah of course like
if i have to if you know time is
crunching and i have to record something
in order to make the deadline then
obviously regardless of if i'm feeling
inspired or not i have to do it but for
the most part it's like
i wake up in the morning and i think
okay do i have to record today
then okay i'll record but if i don't
have to and i don't feel like it i'm not
gonna [ __ ] force myself to do it yeah
i mean there's some days where my mood
is so bad that
i'm i'm clo it's it's going to come off
in the video so i just don't want to do
it but
you know this other day but then also in
that time if okay if i was going to make
a video
i can't do that today i'll do something
else that's productive right for me to
keep on top of things
i don't know but like recently i feel
like i haven't really had that choice
because
i think the past like four videos i've
recorded this week have all been
pre-scheduled yeah on like certain days
uncertainty yeah i mean that's what i
try and do i try and
leave a lot of videos that are in the
works a lot of videos that are
ahead so there's always something i can
work on i don't i don't like to just
finish a video and be like
i got nothing what am i doing like
what's next huh like you know i think
it's
i think it's good to have multiple
things you're working on it's like you
have to plan for the next one
as you're making the produce yeah yeah
yeah which is also something that's
quite
difficult for the way i used to work is
i used to like i had to do one thing at
a time yeah same thing but now yeah i've
got it now i'm juggling like
seven different videos yeah something
like that
for me i'm either working on seven or i
have no idea what i'm working on
no in between i need to change that but
that's why i feel like i
i find it so scary if i was a twitch
streamer because the twitch streamer you
you have to start streaming no matter
what mood you're in and
yeah i feel like it's so much harder to
hard
so much harder to hide that yeah on a
twitch stream rather than a youtube
channel
yeah because it's constantly on camera
yeah this is true i mean
i think the one thing that's even worse
than starting the stream when you're in
a bad mood is when your mood sours
mid-stream oh wow oh yeah totally [ __ ]
[ __ ] caught up yeah when you like
start like all happening you'll start in
like an hour and then maybe you'll get
like a text from someone
that's like telling you like bad news
yeah or maybe someone will say something
that's like real [ __ ] mood or maybe
something
yeah like the stream starts to go wrong
yeah like when stuff starts going wrong
whilst you're streaming
it is so much more mentally taxing
than when you're then starting the
stream in a bad mood because you're like
it can't get worse
yeah i'm already in a bad mood well it's
like it's like [ __ ] up on stage in
front of an audience right
yeah yeah yeah versus just [ __ ] up in
a recording booth
yeah right right yeah it's it's big
difference like like some [ __ ]
clown no this actually didn't bother me
that much but like this is like an
example of something that could happen
so like um
whilst i was streaming on time uh
something happened on my discord server
where one of the mods
made someone else a mod who was
pretending to be a mod
so someone joined my discord server
saying hi for some reason
uh i'm not a moderator anymore and they
had the same profile picture and the
same name as a moderator and someone
else on my server thought
oh yeah that checks out that makes total
sense the moderator yeah and then they
start injecting a bunch of bots into my
server and started like spamming it so
my discord server completely got raided
whilst i was streaming and the whole
purpose of uh this person doing this was
to do it to people who are streaming
live
so they get a reaction so i'm i'm there
it's happening
and my all my chat is like connor connor
your [ __ ] discord's on fire
and i'm like oh okay all right i mean
it'll get dealt with yeah i guess yeah
it's something you can deal with later
yeah that that's like that but it's
frustrating when everyone's like bro bro
you need to look at this look at this
thing i'm like
i don't really give a [ __ ] like i'll
deal with it later yeah yeah
yeah but i was good because that guy was
going around trying to film
tick-tock reactions of streamers getting
angry oh really i was like glad i didn't
know that at the time but i was like i'm
glad i didn't [ __ ] react because i
was like oh okay cool
sounds like an [ __ ] dick thing to
move yeah who does this
don't do that yeah people want attention
right that's what it is nothing new
yeah nothing new in the world you just
got to deal with people always uh
looking to
attack you yeah i get that sometimes you
know i get every now and then
these like obviously people who are just
coming into twitch chat just to [ __ ]
get a reaction out of you just spam
[ __ ] yeah and the best thing i do
that just works is like
i respond to them but in the most
deadpan [ __ ] voice
ever where it's like you're normal yeah
literally just my normal like talking
voices if i'm like responding to chat
and
sure enough they eventually just go away
because that's what they want in the end
the
in the end they want you to be like how
[ __ ] dare you say something like that
you're
such an [ __ ] i already worry too much
about it i understand yeah
yeah but like you know a lot of streams
were just starting off you know can't
really process that right that you're
just you're just buying into the bait
it's hard to wrap your head around that
people are just gonna do mean things to
you
yeah and you don't know why yeah it's
nothing personal there's nothing
personal people
just do this that's part of the job
right yeah i couldn't
i could like there's someone out there
who i have no idea who they are i have
no interaction with them ever i've never
spoken to them
and for some reason they just want to
see bad [ __ ] happen to me
yeah i'm like that's that's really
difficult to accept that that's a
reality
yeah because it takes you a few years i
think you to like actually accept that
yeah right
absolutely i i don't know when i started
just kind of like getting over it and
just being like
all right you know what it's gonna
happen i feel like it was like two or
three years ago where i was just like
probably when it happened enough times
and
it's you just kind of get used to it
yeah you realize you're kind of sad
enough yeah you can't do anything about
it you just gotta
you know not let it ruin your day yeah
you just have to like you think about it
logically right you're being like well
i've never interacted with this person i
don't know what this person looks like
or what they're like as a person
i don't know what they look like right
i've never interacted with them so
they're obviously not saying
all this [ __ ] out of any logical basis
yeah so why would i take any logical
basis out of what no that's true that's
true
it also makes me sad as well because i'm
like man if they actually just spoke to
me i'm sure they'd probably see
yeah exactly a nice guy and they
wouldn't want to do this you know like i
just i don't know
yeah exactly speaking of [ __ ] online
i i want a quick rant
okay um because i know we've talked
about attack on titan like plenty all
right all right here we go all right
it's the greatest weekly attack on the
the weekly attack on titan rant segment
um
i'm getting so [ __ ] tired of spoilers
it's it's gotten to the point now
where my enjoyment of this is getting
[ __ ] ruined
because of spoilers online like logging
on
logging on to twitter now on especially
on a monday
right it's it's like and try not to be
spoiled on attack on titan it's like
trying to go to like a crowded hospital
without a face mask and expecting not to
get covered that's like it's
i've been spoiled now on so many plot
points of attack on titan that i feel
like
as someone who likes to binge shows and
as someone who doesn't want to
i don't want to keep up with it like
weekly right but i feel like
i've i feel like i'm being held at
gunpoint just to keep up with this
weekly
i know i feel you on that you should uh
go through the wiki
um and get every character name and you
should mute them on twitter
that's what i've done have you done that
i've done that and yet still
like i would be on a random thread it
seeps through the cracks
there's no way to stop the cracks and
what i understand what i don't
understand
is why is it that you know when we talk
about spoiler culture
why is it that with a show like attack
on titan it's fine to talk about it as
soon as it airs it's because everyone
expects all the titanton fans expect
that everyone is watching it
as the episode because it comes out
because because like with something like
this
you think it's not okay to talk about it
after it is
i mean i i think there should be a buff
appear like we have this for the
avengers
why can't we not have this for attack on
titan or any other tv show there a
buffer period i don't know yeah i mean
there was a massive [ __ ] buffer
period where like the directors
and everyone was just like please do not
talk about the avengers end game
for like a good two three weeks and
there there is just no
buffer period for like tv shows and like
we're living we're living in an age
where it's like on demand so it's it's
not even the same as it was before
where things are airing on tv and people
watching at the same time
everyone's watching at different times
it's it's literally an on-demand service
this episode is sponsored by bookwalker
gentlemen have you ever heard of
bookwalker before
explain it to me it is an official ebook
store an
app for digital manga and light novels
wow this is maylene's collection right
here this you've
well my god you've normaled this out
that is not that is
i see attack on titan yeah front row
this is the least mailing list i've ever
seen
okay sorry go back to it yeah okay once
you get the app on your android ios
device you can view your purchases
and read them offline if you download
them and the best of all you can
customize the bookshelf like maylene has
she's put the trash taste logo on it
like the true fan she is
most importantly they are simultaneously
releasing
the attack on titan manga is that a good
manga i've never heard guys guys
stop talking there's only two chapters
left so if you don't want to get spoiled
read it
right now on global.bookwalker.jp the
second to last chapter was
just released three days ago so check it
out
right now i'm going there right links in
the description i'm going right now
attack on titan is a good manga i just
came back to confirm i'm reading the new
chapter it is amazing it's amazing gone
it's not good it's amazing go and read
it on global.jp right now
back to the episode i don't know i
really like the community aspect of
you know when an episode airs everyone
talks about it i kind of like that no
but there are ways to talk about it in
ways that are not spoiling
yeah and and there are places there are
like open forums that you have to
physically when i talk about the show on
twitter i try not to mention supposedly
yeah
yeah
every tweet you've you've tweeted about
attack on titan it's fine because
you're not you're not spoiling it but
you still leave open for discussion
right yeah
but i mean i'm still i still need it
right there are some [ __ ] kids
who just do not understand that and
they're just like yeah of course
everyone is watching this
4k picture yeah i can't believe this
character dies
yeah exactly and it's like there's like
some [ __ ]
who will literally like put a full
spoiler and then like put a spoiler
warning five minutes after they just
spoiled the [ __ ] thing they talked
about man
that's it's it's right now
social media is like treading a
minefield i've never i've never
understood
the whole like spoiler warning at the
beginning of a tweet it's like how about
you just don't tweet it
actually it's honestly not gonna lie
it's saved me a few times really because
i'll i'll read the top of it about a
show and i'll see a picture and i'll
quickly scroll because i'm like oh it's
sick there's that's following actually
to me it's just the most pointless
[ __ ] warning it's better than nothing
right no i would rather just you not
spoiling it to be honest but i
understand
right because you know i you know attack
on titan i wish i could
tweet about like the details of the show
a little bit more but i know that
because i have
like quite a large following that yeah
i'm gonna spoil it for someone so i
don't want to do that right yeah
like i literally like every time you
think that if you go on twitter on a
monday
in japan oh it's on youtube and you
haven't watched the newest episode
obviously that's kind of on you well
thanks for the victim blame that
so if you guys don't know attack on
titan airs i think in
the evening in america but and it has
like 5 a.m on a monday
for us so first thing i do every monday
when i wake up is i watch the episode i
don't open twitter i don't do any
because i'm not being funny i know the
internet
they're gonna spoil it there's nothing
you could say here or ever do that will
stop them from doing that so why not
just watch it
i feel though that this attack on titan
incident is like almost unprecedented
like i don't think there's ever been an
anime that has been
where the amount of spoilers on twitter
has been this problem
there's been none and i i remember
because attack on titan season three
part two i thought
you know i got spoiled on some like
minor things but like i don't see that
many spoilers
i see a [ __ ] i see i see it in the
twitter trending page
yeah like that's how you know it's
getting bad when
literally on the when you go to twitter
trending some weeks and i've seen it
some weeks it's it shows you the the
tagline or the hashtag or whatever word
is trending and then underneath
it gives the spoiler okay okay and i'm
like all right okay that is a little
skype
it's that that okay i can understand
that that's never happened no that's not
nice
that has never happened like recently i
i got or like i knew
like it's it's the equivalent of being
like yo something's going to happen with
this character you know yeah
you know nine times out of ten it's
probably a death yeah
it's probably going to be a pretty death
and the problem is that attacking titans
what is
one of the easiest one of the easiest
like shows to spoil out there because
all it takes is like one sentence or one
word i'm pretty sure
i've seen pictures of stuff of like you
know where like the current manga is at
and that like i'm sure that's i've seen
very glimpse mix
when i see it and i recognize a
character i'm like i skip but
i've seen it and i i don't know what it
is so i'm like well if i have no context
this picture i don't know what's going
on
i'm not going to be spoiled until the
moment i see that frame but okay i
i i actually disagree i disagree too
because because like
it i mean it still like spoils your
experience a bit because there's been
like for example there's been so many
like let's say anime or manga or ma
or where you see like a meme panel right
and this meme gets passed around and you
don't know the context of it
but um but then you finally read
or watch whatever shows everyone's memes
about and then it could be like this
really some of the most serious
moments in like media has been like just
ruined for me because i've seen the meme
of it and so the moment happens
and it takes you out and be like oh that
was that was the moment they got me
like right now i'm reading i'm reading
tokyo ghoul because i want i want to see
if the tokyo ghoul manga readers are
right
and i know when that [ __ ] kaneki
panel comes up
i'm going to laugh like i don't know
what the context of it is
but no it's not fun
because to me like i've had this happen
where i i'm not saying that it's okay
to post pictures
read the spoiler warning and you see the
picture for like a fraction of a second
right
like and that way just like no i'm not
gonna watch it somewhere in the back of
your head
that image is subconsciously planted no
no it is right
yeah but here's what i've realized right
when you see an image
of a show right that that you are you're
really into and it's like
it could be ages away you are
making your own theory in your head of
why that image is happening right yeah
if you've seen it right yeah
and so most of the time you're gonna be
wrong right
you're not it's not going to be accurate
so are you are you technically spoiled
because
you you've sort of seen something that's
given you a vague idea of what you think
could be happening but you could be
totally wrong
i honestly want to come into a show with
uh
zero expectations as i can what i'm
saying is that like if
seeing one frame of a panel of a monger
an anime
you know obviously if it's literally a
character dead on the floor yeah yeah i
mean that's being that's been
heavily posted around but if there's you
know a shot of something happening that
i can't quite make out i don't look at
it long enough i just have some kind of
vague
feeling in the back of my head i don't
really think that's a spoiler because
he's because
something like that happened when i
decided to finally watch demon slayer
yeah
and like you know the the first example
we ever had at that was when episode 19
was
trending on twitter right and everyone
was posting pictures and gifs of
that scene yeah right and of course
because i knew
immediately on the training page it says
demonstrate episode 19.
and at that point i hadn't started here
right and i'm like well i eventually
want to get to it
so obviously i'm not going to look at it
i'm going to try and avoid all pictures
but obviously when you're on twitter on
you're on the internet yeah you're gonna
see like
fraction of a frame or a fraction of an
image right and not gonna lie when i
finally caught up the demon slayer and i
got to that
scene in episode 19 i was like this is
impressive
but i feel i would have been even more
impressed if i had
no idea that this was coming like
everybody else and i had no experience
yeah i don't know
a little bit it does take to be honest i
i feel like it does absolutely
i can understand that but i was like
this is epic but this could have been
[ __ ] mind-blowing like it was for
everybody else yeah because i i mean
like i said i i
like we we we we've thought about
spoiler culture when something as big as
the avengers
um was you know aired into game of
thrones but that you could argue that
when it is such a big moment
in any media that obviously it deserves
to be talked about the moment it happens
that you're like oh my god please tell
me someone else has watched this this is
insane
i mean i i feel like this you know
hasn't caught up with
the culture right now because i could
understand that for example
when things were you know airing on tv
he had one run of it and people would go
around the water cooler and discuss what
just happened but now
we're in a time when it's on demand
people watch things when they want to
and yet we still have the same like idea
around spoiling things as
as if people were watching things on tv
because i don't want to watch things as
soon as they yeah i i like pinching it
that's just how i should
you should adapt the way that you go
this is why i miss this is why i miss
like dedicated forums
because with a dedicated forum on a show
right
you won't know anything about the
spoilers of the show unless you decide
to click on the form
no because because the way the way to
adapt is just like i said
how do you solve this problem there is
no there is this there is never going to
go away
so why not just adapt to what's
happening because you can't change at
all because
i don't change with the time because i
don't want to [ __ ] wait an entire
week for the next episode i want to
binge it yeah
because like i hate watching the reason
i said it was because when
when when this idea came up for the
avengers everyone was like yes good
finally someone said it i heard i saw
people spoiling it on twitter
yeah but probably not nearly as much as
without them no
the thing is i don't think it matters
like everyone got [ __ ] shamed for
doing it everyone was just like yo you
did a bad thing
don't don't [ __ ] do this yeah when
when we talk about tv shows and
especially now with attack when titan
it's just everyone's just doing it
really nearly and the the
mentality is well everyone's doing it so
i guess that's okay and that's that's
just
such a hard topic to discuss i wish i
had like more time to
prepare like an actual uh rebuttal but i
mean i
i understand where you're coming from i
just think that you know
in the age that we live in you know now
it's it's it's always going to be like
that
so why not just adapt to what's
happening yeah i mean i
like for me i grew up watching anime
manga um
i i mean i've gotten used to just
watching it in a bubble i like enjoying
like my entertainment in a bubble and
it's only recently that i've gotten
a different kind of enjoyment to see
like to discussing with friends and
everything like that
but when it's something that's um i mean
i mean in a perfect world right you'd go
in a coma
yeah and you would wake up and the
doctor's like bro here's your
crunchyroll account his attack on titan
yeah
don't get up yet just pretend you're
still asleep watch the rest of the
episodes
yeah and then leave and then go on
twitter that's the perfect world right
where you can experience it full run
no breaks no weeks no [ __ ] on
twitter but that's just not how it works
yeah i know i know it's not how it works
i'm just what i'm all i'm trying to
argue is
that why why is it like this why why is
it like
why do people not have a problem with
this i think cuz
i think people do have a problem with it
they just kind of like i think
especially in time i don't know anything
about it in times like now right where
everyone's also at home all the time you
know who you're going to talk to
you're your mom about a ton of titan no
you're gonna
you're gonna go on twitter and talk
about with your friends because
everyone's at home do it yeah but like
but there's other venues to do that in
like isn't that the whole reason why
[ __ ] discord was invented
just so you can create a private room
where you know
the people you're discussing there are
some people who
you know to i you know not me personally
yeah who
you know they don't really talk about
stuff for their friends they just like
to throw it into a void which is a case
right yeah but people like that need to
understand that no one gives a [ __ ]
about what you say
what i'm trying to say is if you want to
discuss it why why not discuss it on
like
the you know relevant subs and stuff
like that you know probably where it
belongs yeah i mean
there's a difference between discussing
spoilers in a dedicated
here the episode here's the episode just
let's just go on a thread versus
let's just post screenshots and stuff
publicly on twitter that anyone
it's the whole assumption that yes
everybody who was a fan of attack on
time and anyone who would ever search
attack on titan
is searching it because they're watching
it weekly
and it's it's that it's that whole
misassumption where it's like and that's
why again like
if you want to discuss the [ __ ] you
know episode that just happened
do it on a private discord server do it
on the [ __ ] subreddit do it on a
[ __ ]
close all we need is spoiler etiquette
we need a system in place where
everyone's degrees
hey this is how you're going to spoil it
yeah i mean that's that's that's that's
all i was talking about i i i was
talking about
yeah i mean it's never going to happen
what i'm trying to say is it's never
going to get to a point where everyone
follows this etiquette and everyone like
this is like a hard and fast rule that
everyone will follow no
all i'm saying is like why is there no
etiquency around this where people were
just like
this should be good it should be common
sense so there's and you know there's
all
also you're thinking to the fact that
okay 90 of people who are posting stuff
yeah aren't intending it so they ruin
your day right but there's 10 of people
who are hoping that they get people to
who they spoil
yeah they get enjoyment what i'm saying
is like what it seemed
like around the avengers is that it was
that 10 of people
that the only spoilers you got were
people who are really looking to ruin
other people's day
right but at least we can we can all
point to them and say yeah they
they were an [ __ ] yeah oh so you
wanted to become
more of a normalized [ __ ] thing
fact that the fact that 90 of people who
are posting spoilers on twitter about a
talk on time aren't being called out for
it
i think it's the problem i i do think
it's
i mean because the anime is arguably
more pop oh i mean it is more popular
than the manga yeah right right i think
it's a little dickish people to post
panels from the manga when you can just
talk about them not post them to twitter
when you know
that the majority of people are anime
only right right that kind of annoys me
because that makes sense to me but even
still just just keep it privately
i get it posting the anime because i'm
like all right everyone's watching the
anime i found it a real problem
where the last time i streamed literally
the first thing i had to say was
don't ask me questions about attack on
titan because the fact that the fact
that people
will like type to me in the chat
immediately like five minutes into me
streaming bank
hey joe what are your thoughts on attack
on time that happens i'm not gonna
[ __ ] talk about it
because why would you assume that i've
caught up to it why would you assume
everyone in this chat is caught up to it
i'm not gonna do that so
to avoid spoilers let's just not [ __ ]
talk about it at all that's the best way
to do it
you wanna talk about it do it in your
own [ __ ] i mean i mean like it's a
different conversation to say if
how much spoilers do ruin a show or ruin
something i mean that's a different
conversation
i just that's a good conversation i i
just i just i just wish there was some
you know
basic etiquette i i you know what i was
mentioning earlier about the picture
that when you see a picture or frame or
a
you know an image from an anime you're
like oh man i wonder what that's all
about
yeah why is kaneki throwing his head
back why you've been doing that yeah
um i i kind of think it's pretty cool
when you um
get when you have an idea of why this is
happening and then it's totally wrong
you're like oh that's how that happened
i thought this was gonna happen
i kind of like that that's kind of cool
not that i want please don't do this
but sometimes when it happens you don't
feel too spoiled and you're like yeah
but i feel
it's a bit of a different story with the
kaneki thing right because it's like
in the manga that's a really serious and
all i can imagine is you land
you know like that's all that's going to
be playing in the back of my head
like the funny way right that's true so
it's just
it really does kind of like it's not so
much a spoiler it's just kind of like
the gap between what you expected and
what actually happened is like a
disappointment right yeah because i i
feel like it really much depends on the
show because like for example
i don't think it's physically possible
to spoil jojo
it's not you can post a panel you can
fully explain what's happening in the
scene and it won't prepare you for it
yeah
yeah experiencing exactly do i remember
that time that
limp dick fought biscuit soup and they
kissed each other to death and you're
like oh is that spoiler yeah i mean yeah
yeah yeah that is how the fight ends
yeah but it you know it does like with
something like jojo it just it doesn't
hurt your enjoyment of the series
part of that is the enjoyment of the
series honestly it probably makes it
better if someone explains what's
happening
exactly and then you can fully
understand it
but a character dying an attack on titan
anyone can understand that and it ruins
it yeah
it's it's a it's a minefield right now
um i just i just wanted to go on a quick
uh first world problem rant uh this this
is an this isn't actually an important
problem i just
i just wanted to go on a knockoff yeah i
mean spoiler culture is pretty fun to
talk about you know
what's going on yeah because like have
you ever been spoiled in like any big
plot points that has
kind of ruined your enjoyment of every
any show
or i think you were amazed i'm amazed at
some shows that i didn't get spoiled
like with certain plot points and attack
on titan i am like how the [ __ ] did i
not get spoiled on this this [ __ ] was so
goddamn obvious that everyone was pretty
talking about it and i'm the only idiot
that didn't know i
obviously won't say it right but there
are moments uh
in recent memory i can't remember the
last time i got spoiled i got spoiled on
the
code gear sandy oh
no which is why i'm so [ __ ]
passionate about like my condolences
which is why i'm so [ __ ] passionate
about because
i was oh i didn't even [ __ ] finish
season one when i got spoiled on that
[ __ ]
how did you get spoiled what happened
because i was on some forum where they
were talking about code geass and i
didn't realize that
oh there's a second season of coke yeah
and people were talking about yeah so
you know the last three episodes of
season two was like you know that was a
crazy ending it wasn't i was like
i is it two seasons you could talk about
the code you're sending now right it's
like bruce willis at the end of
everyone knows i guess i i think my bike
was like
10 years i feel like that's everyone has
seen it right you can spoil
everyone it's it's knowledge right maybe
we shouldn't because otherwise we'll
sound really [ __ ] hypocritical yeah
yeah
i think once enough time has passed and
a show is iconic enough i think
you know it is totally you know fair
game to talk about because
pop culture at that point yeah kiosk
ending is universally
you know loved and and often sighted is
one of the best
endings in anime yeah but you should
know how it is to me though like that
that buffer is still too small right
like i can [ __ ] go ahead and spoil
like something like you know soylent
green because that's like a 60 year old
movie right but like
i feel code guess it's like there are
still kids today
you know coming in probably having no
idea what the show's about right yeah
so i don't i don't want look i've been
through the pain with especially with
code gear so i'm not gonna say [ __ ]
yeah i mean like i got spoiled on
something of a
similar capacity i say uh i got spoiled
in on like the halfway point of death
notes where
something really something big happens
yeah
um that was a manga spoiler as well
that's that's that's the worst
that's the worst that's uh yeah that's
i feel that's worse than getting spoiled
on the ending of death note
that is worse than getting i think it's
worse than any sport because that was
the ending of death
see that's you can talk about that right
that's so iconic like you know what i
mean like there's some things in anime
like that i feel like i feel like i need
to like
make a survey of this and like depending
on the survey results is whether i can
spoil it or not right i feel like
it's like do ninety percent of people
who know me know
the halfway point i know that like
[ __ ] walter white makes meth like
yeah that's
that's pretty like that's
not universally known i mean i just
think that after a certain point where
something is so
well loved and so well known and so
universally like watched
by everyone in said community that it is
it is just fair to just openly discuss
it yeah
by the way please don't spoil code yes
and death note in the comments of this
episode
it's been how many years since death no
it's like what 13
yeah yeah early 2000s right 2006
right since yesterday was 2007.
i think yeah so it's it's been it's been
it's been a long time i'm not going to
do it just in case but i'm i think that
it should be you know
if i'm what's your buffer what's wrong
with an anime fan i would be like
the first thing i'd be like what do you
think about
wow he really just said that you know
there are some things if you say you are
like a fan of x genre
that you should know like if you're like
i love bruce willis movies you should
know that he's dead in sixth sense
right everyone knows that's like the
memes let's just let's just spoil
all the big plot twists like that is
like no no i i get it i get it that's
that's like
me how to be the [ __ ] bad no no that
i mean that's that i get it because
that's become like
part of pop culture now i would say
exactly well it's not it's not it's not
the show anymore
this the the twist is so iconic that the
twist is has become
a part of pop culture himself rather
than watching the show
i've never seen the six sets but i know
the twist because everyone's like
because it's always used as like
anecdotally like oh it's like the ending
of the video
[ __ ] up i haven't watched it i'm not
gonna watch it now are you really not
gonna watch it now
it's still a really good movie i'm
pretty gonna watch it at some point yeah
it's not a good movie
because like i feel i feel like right
now how would you feel if someone
spoiled attack on titan for you
because i ah i think i'd be crushed and
i get over it
you know what i mean would you get over
it because i was not over a win i got
spot for code yes
it depends what how bad of a spoiler
we're talking
right i'm talking like ending of code
yes levels of spoilers because there's
the ending of attack on titan
someone spoiled the ending attack on
titan for you it depends what it was
right because
if i feel like because i already feel
like it's going in a certain direction
right now and if
someone was like confirmed that it was
going there i'd be like kind of sucks
that you confirmed my suspicion
but i'll get over it you know what i
mean would you though
yeah i mix i've been spoiled and stuff
before and i've been like you know what
at the end of the day
the experience is still at banga and
this ain't gonna ruin it right
right i mean i mean look yeah like
granted like you know i finished
code gas and uh even after knowing
that's why it doesn't spoil it it
doesn't ruin it
it didn't wrong so god damn it but
i'm thinking of like the what if
scenario of if i wasn't spoiled
because how much of a mind if a scene is
so
reliant on the fact that you like don't
need to know this plot point
that like the emotions the voice acting
the music the animation
that all of that can't bring like an
emotional reaction out of you
then i don't think it deserves you know
to be like guarded in the first place
but
but at the same time i feel like it took
something away from you it took that
fresh experience from you because
they're like there are there are shows
like i've rewatched code gears right
[ __ ] the ending is excellent every
time
out of none but the like by far the most
unique experience i had was that first
time
that holy [ __ ] moment where i
experienced it for the first time
you can only get that once yeah i'm just
trying to be positive here yeah i'm
trying to say if she goes if you get
spoiled man don't worry at the end of
the world you're gonna be okay
the scene's still good you know it holds
up don't worry i mean i mean
there are even some shows where you
enjoy it more the second time you watch
it but i still value having that first
fresh experience when i don't know
what's gonna happen yeah it's that first
it's that first moment that's so strong
that you look back on it years later and
be like you know it's that obligatory
like
i wish i could erase my mind about
ex-show so i could experience it all
over again you know like yeah
to me that was code geass yeah because i
was like because you don't re-watch
shows which is
your one you've put in a zip folder and
you file it away yeah exactly compressed
yeah you can press that [ __ ] and then
throw it in the trash
yeah i don't know i'm not really i
that's more than that i think that i'm
in like the middle of like i care but i
don't really care
like it's not going to take away my if
the show's good i'm still going to enjoy
it
but i don't feel that most people are on
the end of i don't want anything spoiled
for me don't tell me anything
yeah i want like the full-on experience
you know no i mean i don't want someone
yeah i'd rather have a full-on
experience than someone just [ __ ]
paraphrasing it to me in a [ __ ] way yeah
yeah exactly
i'm tired as [ __ ] so we're gonna end
this episode right now
i hope you know who's you know who's not
tight as [ __ ] though our patrons
they're they're not tired of supporting
us yet yeah look at these great
things they're on that ground look at
these great people i bet if they traded
my pokemon card to me they wouldn't be a
little [ __ ] about it from that
i bet they don't post attack on titan
spoilers on twitter publicly yeah
yeah don't do that please but hey if you
want to support us then make sure to go
to patreon.com
trashtaste also follow us on twitter the
subreddit and if you want to listen to
our audio stuff go over to spotify
yeah and i think that's basically
everything right
i think who wants to do the outro today
the host didn't we didn't we just do the
outro
was that not the outro no that was an
outro was it not no
the the final say yeah the final say
okay okay
bye what do you mean we did an outro i
was such a that was my sister
that was the most flaccid outro i've
ever heard in my life i am flaccid gone
you